the Infinity stones ins in all the
Avengers films there's seven of them
there is six no you have the magic city
snow and the Rosetta there's lots of
people anyone but me really I was you
can't figure out
Lizzie Olsen teaches super super smart
and not just and she's so dry and you
just don't know where she's gonna go
next me in Thor I tried to spear for
with his with the staff of Odin I'd spin
around and kick him in the chest and
know this has been emblematic of Loki's
hidden talent at pole dancing
Chris Hemsworth yeah something about
Downey is like there's a scene in the
film which we shot really late at night
and he'd already shot his side of it
because I was always shooting another
film and he came in especially for just
a few hours to do it with me like he's
just always there you know and he didn't
have to be there and I would personally
have understood if he wasn't there but
he watch because he's that kind of guy
Chris Evans I tell you why because he on
the first Avengers film was the one that
caught us all together we were he would
assemble the Avengers every Saturday
night Winston this guy he's stolen a
smile yeah it's a great world
[Music]